this is a production of Cornell
University
so everyone today I'm going to present
my results on genome-wide Association
study and genomic prediction for mineral
levels in my screen so mineral nutrition
nutrient deficiencies are very can cause
very serious health problems including
so for example iron deficient anemia and
as you can see in this map some
especially in developing nations some
can have over 40 percent of the
population and that can be affected by
anemia and just to put things into
perspective the current status in the
current concentration in maize kernels
are not enough to meet the recommended
daily allowance and this is especially
the case where in the areas were amazed
our staple foods so in the first row
here you can see the RDA for iron zinc
and note that the male and female have
different recommendations and the second
row here are the USDA's maze average in
try kernels so for iOS 2.7 and for zinc
is 2.2 which is like far less than the
recommendation and in the third row here
I'm presenting the harvest as breeding
goal for iron zinc so for iron six
milligram per kilogram and for zinc is
3.8 and that's the goal we're being
working for so there are two goals for
this study we're going to we're trying
to do that reintroduction important
tonight mineral levels in green and this
including this includes performed to
provoke us to help identify the
causative low side and then to build and
validate the GP models
we're using a population so it is a
panel it's a collection of for about
2000 mazing breadline and it captures a
high level of little diversity and as
you can see in the MDS cloudy has like
now sniffs dog sniffs dogs germplasm and
also have like tropical exception
so thanks panel was grown in 2012 and
2013 at Purdue West Lafayette the
Colonel's were then sent to Flinders
University to be grounded and then
performed the icp-ms will perform to
generate the phenotypic data and from
there so this is what Oh like we're
doing so is to generate flux and then
with genotype data from Pangea we're
able to perform to us and GP study so
for now we only have one year's data
which is 2012 so all the results I'm
presenting today are based on one year's
data so I calculated flux so as you can
see here they're near normal
distribution but when we compare back to
what we talked about before so the
average in my panel of iron zinc are 2.3
and 3.1 so for zinc is near the winning
goal but for iron even like my best
clients do not have cannot reach the
harvesters reading goal so we have a
long way to go so this is showing the
pairwise trade correlations so all the
nine traits are positively correlated
and the highest correlation is between
phosphorus and magnesium and iron zinc
are actually moderate moderate Hill
Carla
with 0.53 coefficient so this is good
news because we want to improve the two
traits together in the maze kernel so
some of the some of these traits can be
is very good for GI study like
molybdenum so it is mostly controlled by
a single large effect locus so as you
can see in the Manhattan part here in
chromosome one so this gene is actually
cloned in a wrap topsis and it is called
MOT one which is a memo transporter so
the green line here shows FDR corrected
p-value of 0.05 in contrast I am zinc
there are more polygenic traits so like
you can see here there are a lot of
small Peaks that pass the threshold and
there are much more much smaller effect
there have much smaller effect sizes so
this tells me one thing is that probably
for iron zinc are not good for can
probably a marker-assisted selection are
not enough or good enough for iron zinc
because they're controlled by so many
small more effective QTL so and probably
the better method would be genomic
prediction so for the GP we use five
fold cross validation and ten iterations
and i'm showing the average predicts
ability and actually iron has the
highest predictor predictability of 0.49
and for zinc it's not so bad it has a
predictability of 0.38
and then just to make the folios of our
GP model we apply the GP model train
down eggs to the cement may sign so this
in theory should have high transfer
ability if the two population share a
high number of alleles and as you can
see in the PCA here so the blue dots are
the inks channel two yellow dots is the
similans and the circle actually is a
tropical tropical sub population inside
the inks panel and you can see the
similar lines and the tropical lines
actually totalized okay so I'm showing
the genomic estimated breeding value for
the same Alliance so it's in the green
box plot here is the average GP for CML
using 80 percent of the ink panel as a
training set and we did that for five
iterations and just as a comparison in
the blue box plots we're showing just
the eggs
gbv phalanx training so the
cross-validation and as expected it has
much smaller variation than the similar
line cells first where have smaller
variation than the ink line so which is
to be expected because it just colorized
with one of the aims subpopulations and
we actually just got the symud
phenotypes female phenotype from simit
center and we're trying to do validation
on that so the next step would be to do
fine dissection of the candidate gene
regions and especially for the more
tract or traits and then do validation
of GP modeling
Simmons panel and then ultimately do
improvement up mineral trades with
genomics lecture so with that I would
like to thank my committee member Mike
Elena
Robert all the quorum members for the
support the collaborator my
collaborators Robert and James and also
a harvest class and Simmons for
providing the funding and data thank you
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu